à montigny le bretonneux sur la pelouse
face au bassin de lasours de riz les
artificiers s'activent pas de répit pour
ceux qui vont illuminer le ciel ce soir
la nouveauté cette année se situe au
niveau de l'organisation
la ville a fait appel à une entreprise
familiale d'artificiers installé à
houilles depuis six ans michal chape qui
a eu l'occasion d'aller voir un feu
d'artifice produit par eux et elle a été
emballé par ce feu d'artifice et puis
voilà le contact s'est fait comme ça
c'est une nouvelle société
jlr entreprises artifices et donc toute
nouvelle sur montigny donc des
nouveautés qui seront aussi pour le
plaisir des alimente un événement des
lilas rose ou encore des chandelles
multicolores éclaireront le ciel un
bouquet de lumière qui nécessite une
journée entière d'installation arrivé à
8h ce matin
cette équipe de 8 personnes ne terminera
la préparation que ce soir pour cette
première beaucoup de surprise attend les
habitants
on a des tableaux spécifique l'on a créé
des couleurs pastel dont peut avoir du
du jaune six trous du rose du bleu ciel
ça commence toujours par des maraudeurs
ces grosses explosions non d'avoir
différemment justement pour changer du
feu classique
la ville a dû dépenser près de 22000
euros pour offrir ce spectacle est pour
connaître le thème qui est gardé secret
rendez vous ce soir à 23h